fendage manuel pour les uns fendage
mécanisée pour les autres et un seul but
fendre du bois de chauffage destinés aux
cheminées ces deux techniques
nécessitent un enseignement avec
notamment des consignes de sécurité à
respecter pour ce pas trop on n'est pas
là pour casser le dos vous essayez une
fois ou deux et une fois que tu arrives
pas tu mêles coincé partie d'accord
parmi les futurs élèves du bac
professionnel spécialité forêt yann tual
actuellement seat et jardinier
paysagiste il souhaite se spécialiser
dans ce type d'activité déjà j'ai un
amour de la nature depuis tout petit et
avec mon nom que j'ai fait beaucoup de
coupes de bois de chauffage pour lui et
ça m'a tout de suite plu demandes
administratives marquage des arbres à
abattre découpage et débardage des
morceaux de bois plusieurs pratiques qui
composent la gestion forestière mais
court plus particulièrement c'est dans
l'idée c'est qu'à chaque fois il ya eu
un ensemble une combinaison de plusieurs
modules pour qu'ils aient vraiment une
idée d'ensemble une idée de la gestion
forestière aussi bien environnemental
qu'économique
cette formation s'étale sur trois ans
des modules professionnels accompagnés
de matières générales et des stages de
fin d'année pour acquérir la pratique
sur le terrain sa décision découle d'un
constat simple en ile de france c'est
qu'il ya un potentiel de massy fort
était très important
on est à plus de 270 mille hectares de
forêt parallèlement à ça il ya une forte
demande notamment des professionnels
quand on voit des personnes qualifiées
et compétentes pour gérer ne pas
organiser et également planifier la
gestion forestière et notamment en
ile-de-france entre plusieurs débouchés
technicien forestier conducteur de
travaux ou encore chefs d'entreprises
d'exploitation forestière près de 40%
des postes d'agents forestiers sont
difficiles à recruter
selon l'enquêté besoins en main d'oeuvre
2017 de pôle emploi